So this really has to be seen to be believed,
FOX host Lou Dobbs has been one of the major
nodes of spreading bogus election fraud claims
since November 3rd.
He's done everything from interview that wacky
lawyer, Sydney Powell, to interviewing supposed
witnesses of voter fraud who signed affidavits.
He's been full on with this thing, repeating
and allowing the promotion of completely baseless
claims about companies like Dominion Voting
and Smartmatic and others.
He's really been full on with this thing.
And then suddenly, a couple of days ago, Lou
Dobbs aired a fact check that debunked his
own election conspiracy theories.
What on earth is going on and what's going
on is fascinating.
It turns out that Smartmatic, which is one
of the companies that makes voting machines
about which Lou Dobbs has been spreading this
information, Smartmatic wrote a legal demand
letter to Fox News, Newsmax and on threatening
legal action if they don't retract their completely
bogus claims about Smartmatic.
And the letter actually quotes Lou Dobbs.
It quotes Fox host Maria Bartiromo and others
who simply will not stop making insane claims
about voter fraud.
And it looks like Fox lawyers decided that
the letters had some teeth because Lou Dobbs
ended up airing the following segment, which
please understand this key part.
This segment debunks the lies Lou himself
was telling over the last five weeks.
And Lou just looks absolutely miserable introducing
this segment.
And what's fascinating is that this is clearly
a pre produced segment meant specifically
to get Fox News out of legal hot water.
The questions are asked in voiceover They're
all very carefully worded.
It's stunning to watch this.
Take a look.
Lots of opinions about the integrity of the
election, the irregularities of mail in voting
of election voting machines and voting software.
One of the companies is Smartmatic.
And we reached out to one of the leading authorities
on open source software for elections, Eddie
Perez, for his insight and views.
Eddie is the global director of tech development
at the Open Source Election Technology Institute.
We ask him for his assessment of Smartmatic
and recent claims about the company.
Have you seen any evidence that Smartmatic
software was used to flip votes anywhere in
the U.S. in this election?
I have not seen any evidence that Smartmatic
software was used to delete, change, alter
anything related to vote tabulation.
Smartmatic says its software was never used
outside of L.A. County in twenty twenty.
Do you know whether or not that's true?
That is my understanding.
Smartmatic functioned as the contract manufacturer
for the Los Angeles County voting system,
and that was a customized system that was
effectively built to the county's order.
I am not aware of them having any other direct
customers relationships with election officials
in the United States.
What about Smartmatic and Dominion?
Do you know if they're related, whether one
owns the other, whether Dominion uses Smartmatic
software?
Both Dominion and Smartmatic have individually
and respectively put out very clear statements
from their corporate headquarters, each of
them indicating they are independent companies.
They are not related to each other.
It is my understanding that neither one of
them has an ownership stake in the other or
anything like that.
So that directly debunks the things that Lou
Dobbs and his guests have been claiming, including
as an example that there's some kind of nefarious
link between Smartmatic and Dominion voting
systems.
And then at the end of the segment, they just
cut directly to commercial.
No explanation, no commentary from Lou Dobbs.
Totally abrupt.
Take a look.
And this is right after debunking another
one of Lou Dobbs previous claims says in which
Smartmatic technology was banned in the U.S.
in 2020 due to security weaknesses or wrongdoing.
I am not I'm not aware of any instances where
smart mattocks technology was banned in the
US.
Again, it is my understanding that outside
of one customer in Los Angeles County, Smartmatic
has no presence in the voting technology marketplace
in the United States.
Heading into retirement, right to commercial
with with no word from Lou Dobbs there about
how he has been making the opposite claims
from that piece for about a month and a half
now since the election.
So it seems very clear that this was an attempt
by Fox News just to rectify the legal problem
they created for themselves by airing this
stuff for week after week after week.
Now, it's interesting.
It's not clear to me that this is a huge win.
You and I see this and we immediately understand
they've been making false claims for, what,
five, six, almost seven weeks at this point,
six weeks at this point, the claims have been
completely baseless.
And once it became once it passed a certain
threshold, the companies about which the false
claims were being made got lawyers.
They sent legal letters.
And Fox recognizes that they've got to issue
some kind of legal they've got to do something
here to get themselves out of legal hot water.
That's what you and I see when we see this.
Unfortunately, a lot of Fox News viewers won't
understand or even if they do understand,
they are not going to believe or give that
segment credibility.
They give what Lou Dobbs has been doing the
last six weeks, credibility, but not that
segment.
The saying is something like everybody sees
the headline and nobody sees the correction.
A one week later on the back page of the paper.
That's basically what this is what this is.
Lou Dobbs aired lies that he likely neutralized
for the last six weeks.
They got a legal demand letter from Smartmatic.
We know that's true.
And we are inferring that that's why that
segment was aired again, without any commentary
from Lou Dobbs or him saying, I've been one
of the people telling you the lies for the
last however many weeks.
Maybe that is enough for Fox News to get out
of legal trouble.
But the viewers aren't going to be convinced
by the viewers are going to say what Lou Dobbs
has been saying for six weeks is true.
I don't even know what that segment's about.
I tuned out once once it got away from Lou,
I thought it was a commercial.
I walked away and grabbed a drink in the kitchen.
I don't know if you guys remember, but back
in 2005, Dan Rather on CBS News aired some
improperly sourced documents about George
W. Bush's National Guard service.
And it turns out that the documents they used
were not accurate.
And for CBS executives were fired for that.
And Dan Rather resigned over that mistake.
Fox News on Newsmax won't stop repeating the
same baseless lies about the election.
And the penalty is that Lou Dobbs aired a
two minute pre produced fact check without
even acknowledging that he was one of the
nodes of spreading the disinformation that
that very segment was debunking.
Even in the last ten years, the downfall of
seriousness in media has been absolutely stunning.
And is it better that Lou Dobbs aired it than
not airing it all else being equal?
Given the fact that he's been spreading the
lies, is it better that he heard it?
Yeah, sure.
The reason he heard it, though, is not to
provide an alternative point of view when
that's fact based.
It's because they got a legal demand letter
and it's absolutely pathetic.